at that moment
my hands are shaking as if i'm the one
who did it
my eyes the painter willy karakesi has
established a new form of presentation
accompanied by young rwandan poet he
creates a picture in front of an
audience in just a few minutes
my art can help people
to be creative my art can help people to
change their life
kirikaze works at a gallery named
urabanga which means beauty in
kenyawanda the gallery was founded in
rwanda's capital kigali in 2010.
for most artists here traditional
handicrafts are a thing of the past
with his art karakaze hopes to show
people a mirror of their lives
african people
we are like still have question mark in
our mind
we need other people to think for us we
have to think ourselves for ourselves
then we can do something so i was trying
to do we have a brand but if we don't
use it it's like a butter with drawing
water it means they know there's nothing
inside
artists like willie karacasey need other
sources of income to make ends meet and
must therefore earn some extra money so
he teaches art to schools in kigali
and of course uberranga artists network
and support each other they want to get
out of their galleries
willie carracasa is attending the
opening of the exhibition of a
photographer friend at the gerta
institute in kigali
on this day nothing is for sale the
works are hanging on the walls but in
kagali everything seems to be just a
matter of
time in rwanda is blowing up man like in
2008 there was one
uh art cooperative a place where artists
could go to gather to exhibit their art
and now there's like countless there's
like six seven eight they're opening up
like it seems like a new art space is
opening up every couple months
if he can find a buyer kiara casey earns
300 euros a painting if not he stores
his works in a safe place
you never know says willie caracasey
maybe one day he'll be famous
you